one of the things that's wild about you
man is that you're like hyper smart and
commercial but you also have a lot of
heart I mean you you do a lot of things
because you know that they're the right
thing to do certainly uh your work in
Mobile voting which I freaking love yeah
um is just because you think it's going
to be better for the future I I don't
see a world so so if you get back to a
couple things we've been saying right so
the thing I learned in all my time in
politics and I did city government state
government federal government executive
branch legislative branch I'm a lawyer
like I've seen this from pretty much
every angle
it's that while there are exceptions you
would be one if you were in office my
was certainly one um policy outputs
result from political inputs right and
so if you want to make things better it
has to be in the interest of that
politician to do so and then we did Uber
the same people who don't know who their
state senator is they never vote in a
city council primary were taking the
time to advocate for us because a it was
something they cared about and B we made
it really easy right you can do it right
from the app and so when that happened
we're thinking like holy if people
could vote this way maybe turn out would
be a lot higher and then over the
succeeding years cloud and blockchain
Technology both got better and better um
and so in 2018 I started funding
elections in different states um we
either deployed military people with
disabilities were're voting in real
elections on their phone um we did seven
states 21 jurisdictions they were all
audited by national cyber security
Center all came back clean turn on an
average doubled city of Denver did a
poll of the people participated 100% not
surprisingly said prefer it because to
your point before about like getting a
prescription you know online is supposed
to Happ to go somewhere um but the cyber
security Community especially the people
who are just obsessed with paper ballots
I'm sure you you've come across them
this is the the disingenuousness man
it's like you say hey why don't we vote
uh over the internet on our mobile
phones and be like oh it's not secure
and you can show them 20 20 things being
like it's perfectly secure demos and the
rest of it but the truth is they just
don't want us to be able to vote that
way no they they don't want more turnout
yeah I mean they like things the way
they are if if turnout gets too high
there's a the mobile voting book that I
mentioned that I just wrote that one of
the chapters opens with you know Abner
micko was no I don't so adner mikah was
uh federal judge he was Clinton's White
House counsel um I took his class in law
school at the University of Chicago um
and sort of this just famous sort of
Chicago Legend and in like 19 I don't
know 48 or whatever it was he's a young
man and he walks into the ADI Stevenson
for President office in Chicago and says
I'd like to volunteer and like a ward
boss name was Timo Sullivan sort of
takes a hit off a scar and says who sent
you and he said nobody and so svan said
we don't want nobody that nobody sent
and I think Nick actually named one of
his books uh that and but that's still
the reality today right which is they
don't want the reason they do Jerry
mandering the reason they schedule
elections and dates that are hard to
vote out of they restrict access is they
want to control the electorate and they
especially don't want z and j Alpha when
they come each voting because they're
going to be held accountable for all
kinds of problems that they've let
fester and and let get out of control
and so I think that the the bad news
about politicians is they'll do whatever
they have to do to stay in office the
good news is they'll do whatever they
have to do to stay in office so when
turnout is 12% let's say you're a
republican congressman from Florida um
and turnout 12% in your primary half of
those members half of those voters are
NRA members you know intellectually that
it's crazy that someone can walk into a
store walk out with an AK-47 but you
also know that should you ever say that
you're done uh there's a congressman
from upstate New York in the Buffalo
area named Chris Jacobs who's a
republican super Trumper but there was
if you might remember there a mass
shooting supermarket in Buffalo and he
sort of said we we need to look at some
of these laws he you know he's really
shaken by it they immediately stripped
the line from him so he couldn't run in
the next election and his career ended
or take you know a New York Tech example
Amazon did this headquarter competition
Q2 which is I kind of stole a little bit
of that strategy in in the novel yeah
and they picked New York which was great
and they picked uh Long Island City
which is a district that that you got to
know and the polling showed that the
majority of the district wanted it a
majority of the city wanted it but turn
out in that primary is typically like
14% I got a Mike janys who's a very
smart politician but a politician
through and through understood that that
14% hated Amazon hated Jeff Bezos hated
Tech hated big BS and that he would be
punished politically if he let the deal
go through and so he is the guy that led
the fight me AOC did this too but really
jic did it on a state level it's a guy
that led the fight to to kill the bill
he picked one job his own over 40,000
jobs why because those 14% uh would be
you know right but now let's just sort
of say people can vote in their phones
and turn out that Republican primary and
and jer's primary both 36% so still like
a third just based on the math based on
on the polling the Republican would have
to be for an assault weapons ban because
that's what the majority of his voters
would want jys would have to be for the
Amazon head of course that's the
majority of hit fores would want and so
if we want things to get done we have to
sort of get more and more people voting
and the only election that really
matters is the primary because of Jerry
mandering and the only way I think to
increase primary turnout at scale is to
let people do it securely on their
phones hey YouTube glad you're enjoying
the podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank
you